tschechien möchte ich das toppen
the diamonds wort stier wir schleichen
uns von unten an
fall durch meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einer
weiteren folge minecraft hero auf dem
eintreffen exit auf dem hero server
meine fresse kriegt es endlich meinen
kopf rein
wie gesagt ich nehme seine folge alleine
auf zombies drauf und diese folge werde
ich als wie schon gesagt alleine
aufnehmen und dann kommt in der nächsten
folge kev dazu und dann werden wir
kriegsvorbereitungen treffen gegen den
krieg für den krieg gegen stadt droht
und bis dahin werde ich jetzt erstmal
versuchen jedoch so ein paar ändern man
ihm wie zu klatschen weil so ein paar
ender perlen sind natürlich immer mal
ganz geil da kann man sich auch so
teleport teile mitmachen und mid cap
wird einfach die nächsten fünf sechs
diene ich glaube die komplette nächste
woche die folgende der kompletten
nächsten woche also die folgen bis
weihnachten werden nur vorbereitung sein
da kann ich keine pfeile auf die darauf
schießen nehmen kann keine pfeile auf
die darauf schießen oder ich kann die
pfeile einfach so wieder einsammeln und
ich brauche halt erfahrungen die ganzen
sachen hier zu verzaubern mann ist das
kacke wenn ich die mich die ich hasse
andy teleportiert sich einfach immer weg
direkt bei heatherdale übrigens kommen
die können wir nicht so viel noch mal
eben shader rein damit sie ein bisschen
anschaulicher ist für euch wo hdm es
aber gleich viel heftiger und aus
man könnt ihr mich einigen fach sterben
nein unsere pläne für die nächsten das
volumen doch statt vertikal teile also
unsere pläne für die man kann ich
irgendwie von denen mal sterben
irgendwer unsere pläne für die nächsten
folgen sind halt einfach
ach das war zwar mein handy gerade
unsere pläne für die nächsten ergreift
wenn ich an unsere pläne für die
nächsten aufnahmen sind einfach dass wir
uns mega heftig vorbereiten die punkt
punkt wir werden uns ist und verzaubern
wir werden eine seelen rüstung machen
und zwar würde ich deswegen jetzt mal
liebend gerne eine tief am ohr einfach
was für sie in rüstungen werden die
sportler in die seelen dingsbums packen
und ich würde jetzt liebend gern noch
eine brüstung machen beziehungsweise ich
hoffe mal dass das kann dass es keinen
exit auch existenzen sein denke ich mal
da muss man schon relativ weit zu laufen
da will ich einfach mal mit show
generals unternehmen und zwar möchte ich
eine tiefe haben bei der familie schnell
ist und die welt am liebsten komplett
verzaubern so ich frag mich im sommer ob
er schlafen gehen kann
kannst du kennen ja kann die beiden
golden shoe co geben aber das ist nett
den er aus
so also mit mit zombie werde ich bald
ihr aufnehmer der mit einem goldenen
kuppel gibt das ist dann das beste okay
zum zweck und jetzt haben wir quasi ein
server komplett für uns ja mit extra
aufgenommen weil cap und simon und
dehner und dieser weg von den teil war
hier auch das in der keb sache nach
herstellt würden derart internet machen
da kann schon helfen hintern und rüstung
also was halt gestern passiert ist war
dass sie ihr herz zeit gewesen ob jetzt
aber gegangen wir dachten okay töten wir
jetzt einmal und machen dabei schon
randale bei dem hat aber nicht ganz so
geklappt wie käfer directly getötet
wurde weil simon direkt bei uns war und
deswegen das ganze nicht so geklappt wie
wir uns das vorgestellt hatten
das war aber auch grundsätzlich habe die
neuen stars das heißt wir können uns da
da
leppers da nicht etwas da geht denn das
star stone ja sonst das machen die man
hat dann halt kämpft direkt getötet und
dann hat man was kann ich jetzt machen
stars down machen irgendwas mit mit
obsidian
ich habe keine ahnung was ich auch noch
gucken wollte habe ich hier eigentlich
ein walker spot das meinte cap nämlich
zu mir ob ich eventuell doch ein
boxsport haben walkers wort damit kann
ich aber nichts machen ist das das
richtige motto sport weil da steht
walkers wort dran aber wenn ich jetzt
hier
walkers wort eingebe gibt es sei denn es
gibt nur das
aber ich glaube man texture pack sie das
auch anders aus also das ist das motto
sport
damit soll man sich angeblich
importieren können schreibt mir das
bitte einfach in die kommentare
da meint noch viele dass das brot was
ich habe auf mega geil sei das ist
dieses kleinsten bord was sich ja auch
irgendwo hat und dass ich mit einem
magic mehr angeblich auch irgendwie so
portal ist das brot ihm gesagt ich mir
deswegen portale machen kann und was
alles hätte damit kämpfen noch alles
durchgehen damals noch einige dass ich
von meinem ich warte jetzt erst mal kurz
zu ende
ich bin ein bisschen aus dem konzept
gerade weil das ja echt alles ist war
mega krass die aufnahmen immer gerade
fast direkt im anschluss daran daran auf
so ein hexentanz habe ich brauche
auf jeden fall eine menge ich möchte am
liebsten dings machen
ich mache mir noch einen zauberstab
schön hier
ja ich möchte mal halt am liebsten mob
fall irgendwo im untergrund machen das
müssen kehrt machen weil kämpfen ich
mega viel erfahrung brauchen und ich
nehme gerade nur alleine auf weil halt
sondern nicht wieder drauf kann so aktiv
blöden boote bei euch auch nicht so das
ist nur die wirst also klug dass ich das
nicht getrunken aber eigentlich ne
welcher directly gestorben so diamond
award da kann ich den ganzen
verzauberungen runter machen
dann habe ich vielleicht wieder so ein
bisschen energie
die muss ja auf jeden fall auch
mitnehmen nicht mal meine damen skype
mit habe ich dir habe ich dir habe ich
selber hab ich sie da das dakar hat die
sache noch unternehmen ändert schild
alle meinen auch dass man wenn man
ändert james ward in der hand hat dann
bekommt man da erscheint dann kann man
nicht vergiftet werde natürlich gerne
austesten cracken reitsport hab ich
jetzt auch noch von diener
dass levi metals wort werde ich gleich
auch noch mal reparieren
was ich mir auch noch gucken wollte was
da wo ich das jetzt gerade dass der doch
diese place place magma cube brauche ich
dafür
dafür brauche ich einen von den blazer
ja ich brauche da das machen andere mal
so mein haus hier werde ich auch noch
verzaubert zaubern anders bauen ist so
blöd dass man diese 20 minuten gebunden
ist und ich deswegen nicht immer vor
beeilen muss aber ich wollte auch meine
rüstung jetzt mal ein bisschen
reparieren erst mal mehr reparieren muss
ich gar nicht sondern ich wollte die
verzaubern mache ich jetzt mal eben ganz
kurz so erstmal kommt hier alles
mögliche drauf also es gibt weil das
kostet ja selbstverständlich nichts bei
einem zauberstab
ansonsten kann jetzt mehr draufpacken
achter bleibt die kappe tätig weiß nicht
was das letzte was der unterschied jetzt
so electric darf da wollte ich das von
unten möglich dass da von unternehmen
ich weiß nicht warum ich das kann ich
jetzt hier von unternehmen hiervon kann
ich das unternehmen
komisch jetzt habe ich mich wieder 37
level das jetzt relativ gut
warum konnte ich das jetzt nicht
unternehmen keine ahnung vielleicht geht
das allgemein ich dennoch atom-u-boots
das bringt da kann ihr unternehmen kann
ja auch nicht unternehmen nicht geringer
machen kann ich auch nicht mal
vielleicht weiß noch nicht benutzt ist
klasse ich damit mal eben ganz kurz
irgendwie chocobo töten hier
wenn man so viele gelbe trikots liegen
alle überflüssig
die sind jetzt sogar so dass möchte
natürlich sagen jetzt nicht kaputt
machen
mir hat das jetzt ein bisschen
verbessert sondern auch behinderte hin
die ist übrigens liebe hin die bis in
die ist jetzt wieder normal haben wir
nicht irgendwo ein paar da sind schweine
sowas bringt dieser zauberei okay weil
ihr institut
ich brauche noch implantiert wir
schleichen uns von unten an
so und ich brauche die frist und weil
ich hasse es wenn ich so langsam hier
oder auch münchen ich so langsam
vorankommen ihr seht ja der elektrik
darf wie schnell der kaputt ist einfach
mal das ist so traurig aber egal
deswegen den iwf aufnehmen dass wir da
eventuell ein paar sachen sehr sehr
viele farben werden wir können werden
tun machen sein handeln ich hoffe dass
das jetzt hier unter krieg eigentlich
schon
also sonst ja gut kriegt dann wohl
einfach nicht darunter
das habe ich auch noch verzaubert mit
sharpless und zwar werde ich jetzt das
so machen so an breaking eins muss man
drauf lassen das ist tricky vsp kann ich
gar nicht ganz runter machen was ich
feiere ist wirkt einfach mal kurz darauf
so verzaubert von sechs level wenn ich
das jetzt reparieren
costas einst und jetzt packe ich mich
die ganze sache nie wieder drauf noch
beck will ich eigentlich gar nicht drauf
haben
lu ting ist auch relativ egal an
breaking ist wichtig so stil als auch
wichtig denn es sollte hatte als wichtig
soll stieler solcher stil draufpacken
hätten die leute focus money so auch ist
wichtig weil ich deswegen besser
schlagen kann
soost filmen und 58 liter rick wright
bei welcher zauber habe ich noch 20
store steel us steel 1 sollte reichen
meinten die meisten natürlich noch sechs
level aber ich hab ne menge schon drauf
das ist relativ gut bleibt oder breit
oder wie das heißt ich auch ganz gerne
auf zehn grad letting afterlife es gar
nicht was jetzt noch alles bringen soll
aber ich habs jetzt verzaubert
so meine rüstung relativ egal dies noch
relativ voll da habe ich auch auf jeden
tag darauf die werde ich allerdings auch
noch verzaubern müssen die pächter von
ein paar sachen die ich hab die ganzen
rüstungsunternehmen seine spitzhacke
hier das ändert ein spot repair
hallo diese kann ich das nicht
reparieren
die sowieso unscharf sagt wenn du fällst
cam ist allgemein voll packe ich glaube
da würde ich mal meine neue holen ich
bin noch voll dunkel zu hause gleich
viel besser
wieso kann ich das nicht reparieren muss
das hier einpacken
wie kann ich das nicht reparieren
ich weiß nicht warum jedenfalls sind
jetzt auch die verzauberung der hand weg
na gut die giants vortag ich herkomme
ist jetzt die gleichen das jetzt erstmal
somit welches von den beiden hat
eigentlich mehr schaden ich weiß gar
nicht ich brauche jedenfalls unbedingt
darum ist okay
ich werde dass bald alles sortieren dann
macht euch mal keine sorgen es wird
schon noch kommen wenn diese kiste auch
noch voll ist dann werde ich anfangen zu
sortieren so der mc trix tag werde ich
immer mitnehmen ihr seid alle unnötig da
sie noch weiter drin
solche sachen nenner ist einfach so da
kisten und da sind auch kisten die
können das ist einfach und herzlich von
mir so ein paar fackeln sind ja auch
noch fackeln irgendwann ein sind da
fackel
ja da sind auch noch ein paar fackeln
nein nein nein da sind auch wieder zehn
kisten die habe ich dann bitte so viele
kisten 9 30 kisten einfach mal ja die
schilder sollen angeblich relativ gut
sein
christel wo ich habe keine ahnung ob der
besser ist als ein als dieser liga bank
eigentlich ist der regenbogen ja besser
oder
ich würde sagen der legia bogen ist
besser ja keine ahnung
die buchschlager mal den weg so also die
scan rüstung habe ich die muss ja noch
verzaubern
und wenn ich dann auch mexikaner sachen
kriege kann ich mir die fifa machen
übrigens leute mein was man diese zwei
finger bedeuten keine ahnung macht das
jetzt mal so hier irgendwie voßkuhle zum
einleiten
ich weiß nicht warum ich habe sieben
goldene äpfel wieso fällt mir das denn
jetzt an porsche generation' versucht
die vermehrt setzte auf sich eigentlich
so habe die rein zustands kurzem
fuchs darf blabla gilt skeleton änderte
ich wollte da hab ich die wahl habe ich
die dann eingelegt meine gefäßen da
herr [ __ ] wichtig behindert wartenberg
überhaupt genannt
die hießen überhaupt keeper
wäre ich jetzt eben gelegt das kann doch
nicht sein dass ob ich das weg gelegt
habe habe ich die nicht mehr
ich habe mir doch noch die essenz keeper
gemacht oder habe ich die nähe zum dings
verloren ich irgendwo verloren
muss man das geld die diamonds zeit die
ich immer gemacht habe wie geht hier
alles verloren wird wenn dies geist noch
hier irgendwo ist dann muss sich das der
andere das irgendwie dann auch so dass
auch keine auch keine auch keine auch
keine auch keine
und weil ich meine meine solo-platte
wenn ich die soll cages setzt auch
nichts vor hat mir echt enttäuscht oder
ob ich das alles in einem rucksack
gepackt
gut ich bin nicht enttäuscht ich die
ganze sache hier und zwar wollte ich das
hier jetzt nämlich eben testen
ich laufe nämlich jetzt mal mit einer
sky zu irgendeinem ob der hier
vielleicht irgendwo in der umgebung sein
sollte hoffe ich doch mal hallo
irgendwelche mohawks irgendwann werden
wir wirklich wieso nämlich eigentlich
mein chocobo irgendwann werde ich
wirklich dann mal einfach so denke ich
ziemlich so richtig richtig in einem
livestream wenn ich das irgendwie
hinkriege wenn ich weiss und nachts um 4
uhr keiner wird auf den server kommen
und wird mich umbringen oder so dann
werde ich stream und wo auch kein
zuschauer da als wo es aber trotzdem
legal ist das extreme weil sie alles
aufgezeichnet wird
wo ich einfach nur woods wagt und so da
kann ja auch nichts für das ist einfach
mein internet
aber da wäre ich dann einfach mal so
sachen machen die man sonst in der folge
nicht so machen möchte so mega
langweilig gesagt zum beispiel wie zum
beispiel damals die essens farben bauen
oder irgend sowas
und jetzt werde ich denke ich einfach
mal mit jockey immer diese richtung
gelaufen
immer nur in eine richtung ach so hier
kann ich das eigentlich direkt schon mal
ausprobieren
hallo bestehen
pizza.de bleibt stehen konnten
ich muss ich muss ganz nah an ihm dran
einigen konnten so noch zwei
mann
der angst vor mir oder kupferstecher 10
jetzt habe ich in elsenz die haben jetzt
in dem song keeper drin
und jetzt jetzt dort eine von 20 zoll
und jetzt brauchen wir eventuell noch
mehr ist es glaube ich ihnen das geht am
besten wenn man irgendwo bei einem sport
als oder so wo halt die ganzen essenzen
sind das so wir wollten ja immer nur in
diese richtung laufen auch jetzt noch
müssen immer in diese richtung also ziel
kann die richtung nämlich nach der weise
wie ich zurückkomme wenn ich mit cap
aufnehme ach komm ist jetzt egal wollen
wir da vorne einfach nochmal rein da
hatte ich jetzt mal so ein bisschen
angst aber wenn ich jetzt die rüstung
hat und so dann sollte das ganze relativ
sein ich habe jetzt auch gar kein gar
keine kacke hier mit vista
da keine sachen die mich irgendwie mit
dem ihr den ich joe kiki heilen kann
sprich alter wir sind so viele da fällt
auch schon direkt runter einfach
so kann ich jetzt nicht hier
hallo achim setzen jetzt hier eben bei
ihnen die angst sind die mega stark
nehme ich kann hier einfach so boxen
glaub ich meine folge seitlich vorbei
nutzt du auch noch eben tot
sowas haben jetzt alles so geklappt ich
glaube nicht mal was gutes
hier sind noch ein paar lustige sachen
drin
flori tempel diamond lancer chris rogers
hier noch was dass sich für ketten jetzt
nichts mehr drin das kann ich eventuell
mitnehmen für einen zauber tisch
revolver haben das ist nämlich einfach
mit witzigen den luxus dass ich brauche
meine achse mit abzubauen
oder nicht
ich sagte kommt man ganzes bücherregal
gab es nicht mal der zeit wurde ein
ganzes bücherregal rauskam oder in
diesen natürlich mich gerade
block auf gold das ist geil damit kaum
ins goldene äpfel machen oder es einfach
zu gold machen und dann und uns dann
evidente irgendwelche anderen sachen da
rausholen
herr wieder ob ich jetzt eigentlich
letzte mal nicht gesehen oder war ich
überhaupt schon mal wahrscheinlich wird
einfach nur die tränen
hierbei irgendwann hat sich einfach die
tour mitgenommen dann kann ich ja gar
nicht mehr was ich mich mitnehmen könnt
so aber ich will jetzt einfach mal die
ganzen bücher mit valentin dann braucht
man die auf jeden fall
das habe ich total vergessen dass mit
dieser magnet okay dass mit dieser menge
teils sache ja die ganzen sachen zu
einem hingezogen werden
ich nehme jetzt einfach mal nur sich 26
oder so und dann werde ich auch direkt
wieder an cut machen weil ich über ziehe
schon wieder soll man ja nicht so aber
ich habe am anfang die kreisstadt
relativ enger ich glaube ich jetzt
kirche 26
so freundin nächsten folge werde ich
dann hier noch ein bisschen gucken was
es hier noch so viele sachen gibt das
sind auch noch ein paar sachen drin
und hier sind auch noch ein paar sachen
das wird auf jeden fall megageil also
noch ein paar geile sachen die ich mir
wohl werden kuchen
davon weiß ich jetzt mal ganz kurz ab
und ich sagen dies zufolge ist mit
vorbereitungen für den krieg wenn es
euch gefallen habe ich mich über eine
positive oder negative bewertungen
freuen
halt wie es euch gefallen hat und dann
würde ich sagen schreibt mir doch mal in
die kommentare an welchem tag die folge
gerade guckte die folge gerade am
siebzehnten oder guckte sie an einem
anderen tag